Thank you, Joseph.
I know something about
hosting parties,
so I want to congratulate you on
being the perfect host tonight.
You set the table,
faded into the background,
and let the interesting
people shine.
-Bravo.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
What a dais.
Dennis Rodman, where do I begin?
If you had told me back
in the '90s that Dennis Rodman
would be negotiating a
nuclear-arms agreement in 2018,
I would've said, "Dennis Rodman
is alive in 2018?"
[ Laughter ]
Local comedian Dom Irrera
is here.
Dom, I know your career
never really took off,
but if you just keep doing
what you've been doing,
I'm sure you'll eventually
be discovered
by your landlord two weeks
after your heart attack.
[ Laughter ]
And, Edward Norton,
I am a huge fan.
You are amazing.
Edward takes the craft
of acting very seriously.
He prepared to play
the Incredible Hulk
by spending 30 years
losing his temper
and turning into
a giant asshole.
[ Laughter ]
Nikki Glaser,
you have it all --
the name of a professional
porn star
and the body of
an amateur porn star.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I'm a big supporter
of the #MeToo movement,
but remember, Nikki,
"me too" shouldn't just be
what a guy says to his friend
when he tells him
he had sex with Nikki Glaser.
Noted.
Well, there are so many
celebrities here tonight.
We have men from movies,
women from TV, and Lil Rel from,
I'm guessing,
the California Raisins?
[ Laughter ]